[Music]
apple just released a new version of
their famous editing software final cut
pro but apparently it's so different
from the last version of final cut uh
video and film editors all over
hollywood are having a very hard time
adjusting to it okay
well our editors here at conan are some
of the best in the business they
actually like the new software in fact
they've prepared this video statement
voicing their support for the new final
cut pro
hi i'm dave greco one of the editors
here at conan
we actually really like the new version
of final cut pro
we used it to edit the video you're
watching right now hey this is dan dylan
interface for final cut x's best of
itunes and imovie all right inside final
cut x
that's great good hey my name is rob ash
what i really like about the magnetic
timeline is it allows me to put
everything in the right sequence and to
keep everything in sync
it also makes it very easy to animate
titles
like this
final cut x also makes it really easy to
match color between two different scenes
the new interface for final cut x is
awesome it allows you to tag all your
clips so you can always find the clip
that you need
the new interface for final cut x is
awesome oh and the last thing i want to
mention
[Applause]